democratic presidential candidate joe
biden wants you to believe that his two
trillion dollar
plan to combat climate change is a bold
new agenda
to save the planet the on-rushing
climate crisis
left unchecked it is literally an
existential threat to the health of our
planet
and to our very survival in fact it's
the same worn out jobs program for
democratic party interests
that he's been pushing since he became a
senator in the early 1970s
i see the steel that will be needed for
those windmill platforms
towers and ladders i see the ports that
will come back to life the longshoremen
the shipbuilders the communities they
support climate change is real but it's
not the end of the world it's not even
our most important environmental problem
writer and activist michael
schellenberger was named a hero of the
environment by time magazine in 2008.
his new book apocalypse never makes the
case that the climate alarmism which has
become a central part of the democratic
party's platform
is flat out wrong and counterproductive
for both the environment
and the economy the two most important
things anybody needs to know about
climate change
are that deaths from natural disasters
have declined 90 over the last 100 years
they've declined 80
over the last 40 years including in very
poor countries we should be celebrating
this like every day
day of the week um and then the other
thing is that carbon emissions have
peaked
um in rich countries they're going to
peak in four countries in the next
10 20 years maybe most a major problem
of biden's rehash of the green new deal
is that renewable energy sources such as
solar power
simply can't scale to provide the
electricity that modern society needs
so the problem with renewables is just
it's just physics
renewables are for you know
pre-industrial subsistence farming
societies
their low energy density it's woods
sunlight water wind they're all
very low energy density fuels or flows
fossil fuels are much bigger increases
in energy density they're what allow us
to have cities
before biden revealed his massively
expensive green energy plan
he had already promised more than six
trillion dollars in new spending over
the coming decade
paid for through a mix of borrowing and
hikes and incoming corporate taxes
this comes at a time when the 19
lockdown in emergency spending
will push the national debt above 100 of
gdp
by the end of 2020 and the federal
government is running larger deficits
than it did
even at the height of the financial
crisis
shellenberger says that if politicians
were really serious about combating
global warming
they would get behind fracking and
nuclear energy which is both clean and
practical
biden doesn't mention nuclear power
though because it won't create jobs for
longshoremen and shipbuilders
or fulfill any other progressive fantasy
such as his dream of a modern day
civilian climate corps
based on the new deal civilian
conservation corps
the problem that nuclear energy poses to
malthusians
who want to control society and restrict
growth and do all the things that we
know
what the people that call themselves
environmentalists want to do
it's threatened by nuclear energy
because nuclear energy means you have
infinite energy infinite fresh water
infinite fertilizer that means you have
infinite foods so
nuclear eliminates resource scarcity
when i think about climate change the
word i think of is
jobs good pain
union jobs joe biden's clean energy plan
might even help get him elected
but if past is prologue it won't create
many jobs or help heal the planet
it'll just mean spending gobs of money
we don't have
in a massive giveaway to special
interests